Ja, Herr Herr Keidel, das ist meine Names. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzerstätig.
Ich würde das Aufnahmegespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Bevor wir Ihre aktuelle Beschwerde kommen, soll ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Gerne.
Ja, falls irgendetwas unklar ist, fragen Sie gerne nach.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Schmidt Ralf.
Schmidt Reif.
Ralf.
Ich möchte Ihre Vor- und Nachname bestabieren.
Schule, M-I-T.
Schmidt.
M-I-T oder D?
DT.
DT, okay.
L-A-L-F.
Den erinnert man auf meine Vornahme.
Herr Ralf, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 43 Jahre alt.
43.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 20. Januar 1982.
82.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,73 m groß.
Und wie?
Ungefähr 75 Kilogramm.
Okay, vielen Dank für diese Informationen.
Was führt Sie zu uns?
Ich habe starke Schmerzen auf der rechten Seite.
Das hört mich auf, das wird immer schlimmer.
Was meinen Sie?
Rechte Flankenseite.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschewerte?
Ich habe diese seit zwei Tagen.
Herr Ralf, trauen Sie die Schmerzen irgendwo in Körperteile aus?
Oder noch Flankenbereich?
Seit heute Morgen ziehen Sie ein bisschen in die Leiste.
Könnten Sie bitte die Schmerzen bescheiden?
Ehe du, Schmier,
oder Wellenförmige,
oder Kramfartige, wie charakteristisch?
Es sind manchmal stechende,
aber eher wellenförmige Schmerzen.
Verstehe.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala?
Von 1 bis 10, 1 bedeutet leichte Schmerzen,
10 bedeutet unverträgliche Schmerzen.
Es ist unterschiedlich. Manchmal sitzen Sie bei 4,
manchmal sind Sie aber auch bei 9.
Da kann ich gar nicht halten.
Momentan geht es, bei 6, 7.
Aber ich habe eben auch eine Ibuprofen eingenommen.
Vielleicht deswegen.
Ich habe heute ein Einglom,
gestern, vorgestern viel eingenommen.
400 Milligramm, richtig.
Diese Medikamente hat Ihnen geholfen?
Wenig, immer so für 3 Stunden.
Sie haben gesagt,
aktuelle haben Sie 7.
Brauchen Sie aktuelle Schmerzmitteil?
Oder können wir fortsetzen?
Wenn es nicht lange dauert,
kann ich das noch ein bisschen aushalten.
Aber gleich würde ich mich freuen,
wenn ich die Schmerzmedikamente bekomme.
Ja, kurzzeitig, 10 Minuten.
Es wäre besser, wenn Sie die Schmerzmitteil
aushalten können.
Alles klar.
Vielen Dank.
Das ist erstmalig oder haben Sie
früher ähnliche Beschwerden?
Ich habe das zum ersten Mal jetzt.
Herr Neust, ist bei Ihnen andere Beschwerden,
zum Beispiel FIBA oder Schmerzhafte,
Urin-Ausscheidung,
andere Beschwerden aufgefallen?
Nein.
Keine FIBA, keine Stülfrost,
keine Schwitzen.
Wenn ich mehr kommen,
dann ist das schon sehr stark.
Dann kann ich schon sagen, dass ich etwas schwitze, aber so nicht.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Haben Sie noch andere
Schmerzen, die schmerzen,
die Linder oder Verstärkungen?
Ich habe etwas Wärme draufgetan.
Eine Wärmflasche habe ich draufgetan,
das hat aber nicht geholfen.
Nicht geholfen.
Wie ist Ihre Appetit in letzter Zeit?
Gut.
Haben Sie Übelkeit und Erbrechen?
Nein, aber wenn ich Schmerzen komme,
habe ich auch etwas Übelkeit, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber das geht wieder weg.
Nur beim Schmerzen?
Nicht immer.
Auch nicht bei jedem Schmerz, manchmal.
Okay, manchmal, verstehe ich.
Haben Sie im letzten Zeit Sturrgang oder Wasserlassung Probleme?
Nein.
Haben Sie im letzten Zeit Ab- oder Zugenommen?
Haben Sie Herzstolpern oder Atemprobleme bemerkt?
Das auch nicht.
Auch nicht, okay, verstehe ich.
Ich möchte ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer kranken Vorgeschichte stellen.
Leiten Sie an chronische Erkrankungen,
z.B. Bluthochdruck oder Blutzuckerwerte
oder andere Probleme?
Ich habe keine Vorerkrankungen.
Keine, okay.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ich wurde einmal an meinen Mandeln operiert.
Das war, wo ich 10 Jahre alt war.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf
äußere diese Ibuprofen andere Medikamente ein?
Normalerweise nicht.
Nein, ich nehme in der Regel,
ich krank für die Ibuprofene.
Ist bei Ihnen
eine Allergien- oder Unfältiglichkeit bekannt?
Nur gegen Hausstaub.
Hausstaub.
Wie reagieren?
Yukreiz, Augen tränen, manchmal niesen.
Herr Rauf, könnten Sie mir bitte sagen,
ob Sie rauchen?
Ich rauche nicht.
Haben Sie früher geraucht?
Ab und zu, aber ich habe noch nie Geschachtel gekauft.
Okay. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Sehr selten.
Vielleicht ein, zwei Mal im Jahr.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine routine Frage. Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Ja, in meiner Jugend habe ich mal Cannabis geraucht, aber aktuell nicht.
Könnten Sie mir bitte sagen, ob Ihre Eltern noch leben?
Mein Vater ist verstorben, meine Mutter lebt noch.
Es tut mir sehr leid.
Woran ist er verstorben?
Frank Reaskarzinom.
Mit welcher Jahr?
60.
Mutter? Hat er nicht?
Nein, ich habe nicht.
Mutter? Hat eine chronische Erkrankung?
Sie hat Bluthochdruck.
Sie hat auch eine Herzrhythmusstörung.
Dafür nimmt Sie Medikamente ein.
Haben Sie Geschwester?
Ich bin Einzelkind.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Insbesondere Corona oder anderen Kindern?
Ich denke schon.
Machen Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ich gehe regelmäßig spazieren, fahre Fahrrad.
Das versuche ich alle 2-3 Tage zu machen.
Was macht man sich beruflich?
Ich bin Bankkaufmann.
Entschuldige, ich habe nicht gut gehört.
Bankkaufmann?
Kaufmann.
Ich habe nicht gut gehört.
Ich bin Bankkaufmann.
Ich habe die erste Worte nicht gehört.
Okay, verstehe.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet und habe 2 Kinder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ich bin gesund.
Ja, die sind gesund.
Ich möchte Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden kurz zusammenfassen.
Sie haben seit 2 Tagen recht flänke Schmerzen
im Laufe der Zeit schlimmer geworden.
Heute Morgen schüttert die Schmerzen.
Heute Morgen leistet Bereich.
Die Schmerzintensität ist ungefähr
100% verheiratet.
Das ist ungefähr hier und bis neu.
Das ist erstmalig.
Wärme und Ibuprofen haben Sie benutzen.
Aber das hilft nicht.
Manchmal haben Sie Übelkeit.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, aber ich habe wirklich sehr stark Schmerzen.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Das wird jetzt auch ein bisschen mehr.
Wenn es geht, würde ich gerne eine Infusion haben.
Ich werde sofort einen Wennenzugang legen
und geben Ihnen eine Schmerzmittel.
Was geben Sie mir denn?
Vielleicht Metamizol.
Was ist das?
Aber eine Novalginalogie habe ich.
Ich habe eine Novalginalogie.
Aber ich habe gefragt, ob Sie eine Alergie haben
oder ob Sie eine Unverzwecklichkeit haben.
Ich dachte, Sie meinen jetzt gegen Nachhung.
Ich finde, dass Sie Medikamente meinen.
Okay, eine Novalginalogie haben Sie.
Vielleicht geben wir eine narkotische Schmerzmittel.
Metamizol.
Okay, das kenne ich nicht.
Ich hoffe, ich werde nicht allergisch negieren.
Wie reagieren Sie?
Ganzkörperausschlag, überall.
Möchten Sie noch etwas fragen oder hinzufügen?
Nein, ich möchte, dass mir geholfen wird.
Ich möchte die Schmerzen weghaben.
Das ist wirklich sehr unangenehm.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Ja, ich habe einige Fragen.
Gibt es etwas, was die Schmerzen verstärkt?
Zum Beispiel Laufen, Flachliegen?
Ich habe die Schmerzen sowohl im Liegen, im Gehen.
Also ich wache auch oft auf mit den Schmerzen seit 2 Tagen.
Das ist schon sehr anstrengend für mich.
Haben Sie die Teipersgefühle oder die Krippels-Lehmung am rechten Bein bemerkt?
Nein, gar nicht.
Haben Sie die Schmerzen im Bein wasserlassen?
Nein, habe ich auch nicht.
Okay, danke schön.
Müssen Sie sehr oft wasserlassen und gab es in Blut?
Normalerweise, ich muss normal Wasser lassen.
Keine Blut.
Hab ich nicht gesehen.
Danke.
Trinken Sie genügend Flüssigkeit oder Wasser täglich?
Ich trinke Wasser, ja.
Wie viel zum Beispiel täglich?
Ja, so 1 Liter vielleicht.
Das ist aber zu genug.
Bitte?
Das reicht, oder?
Nein, nein, nicht reicht.
Das reicht nicht?
Nein, Sie müssen...
Trinken auch Tee, Kaffee, reicht das nicht aus?
Wie viel Kaffee trinken Sie täglich?
Also 3 Tassen bestimmt.
Okay.
Noch eine andere Frage, Kollegen.
Sie sind 43 Jahre alt.
Wie lange haben Sie letzte Vorsorge-Untersuchung gemacht?
Was meinen Sie mit Vorsorge-Untersuchung?
Routine-Untersuchung.
Beim Hausarzt oder?
Hausarzt, beim Hausarzt.
Also ich war noch letztes Jahr beim Checkup gewesen.
Ja, okay.
Alles ist normal, sind normal, oder?
Mein Hausarzt sagte, Blutwerte sind okay.
Okay, danke schön.
Haben Sie in der Saison Verletzung?
Ich habe mich nicht verletzt, weil ich mich erinnern kann.
Was passiert vor zwei Tagen?
Wie meint ihr, was passiert?
Auslöse, oder?
Auslöse, ja.
Keine Ahnung, die Schmerzen kamen auf einmal, ja.
Okay, danke.
Was ist das für eine Saison?
Die Schmerzen kamen auf einmal, ja.
Okay, danke.
Also ich bin nicht gefallen oder sowas in der Arbeit.
Die Schmerzen kamen plötzlich.
Haben Sie vielleicht eine Schwierigisten aufgeroben?
Erinnere ich mich nicht daran, nein.
Also die Schmerzen kamen auch abends, als ich zu Hause war,
als ich am Telefon war, dann kamen die plötzlich vor zwei Tagen.
Ich habe noch einen Tag abends angefangen.
Ich habe keine Fragen gestellt, ich habe keine.
Ich frage mich, ob ich aus dem Haus war oder so.
Ja.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Kann ich anfangen?
Ja, ich möchte einen Noriam-Patienten vorstellen.
Herr Schimitrandt ist 43-Jährige.
Patient zeitlich, örtlich und persönlich orientiert, in normal gewichtigem Ernährungszustand und in Beschwerde bedingte, deutlich reduziertem Allgemeinzustand.
Der Patient stellte sich heute auf unserer Station mit seit zwei Tagen bestehenden, problemdientenden, persistierenden, stehenden, wellenförmigen Stümmerzeln im rechte Flankbereich vor.
Nach Aussage des Patienten sei die Schmerz im Laufe der Zeit schlimmer geworden. Die Schmerz würden sich im Leistenbereich, seit heute Morgen, in Güynalbereich aus Schütteralen,
die Intensität der Schmerzin wurden von vier bis neun von zehn auf nr. Skala angegeben.
Aktuell hat der Patient sieben gesagt und die Einnahme von Ibuprofen hat mehrmals Ibuprofen, hat bei ihm nur weniger Verbesserung gebracht.
Außerdem haben wir bei ihm wenig Anwendung nicht geholfen. Darüber hinaus klagte er über Nausea während der Schmerzin.
Auf die Frage nach Fiberschuttefrost und Wasserlassenprobleme wurde verneint.
Die Bestiftung von Anäse bis auf oben genannte Symptome ist unaufwählig.
Anvor Erkrankungen sei er keine Entschuldigung.
Er sei wegen von alten zehn Jahren Tonzielvergroßung eine Opfer.
Er sei nicht regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf äußerst Ibuprofen ein.
Auf die Frage nach Allergien und Verträglichkeiten gab der Patient an auf Hausstauballergie mit Prüratis und Rhinoconjunktivitis zu reagieren.
Außerdem hat er mit ganz Körperreaktion darauf reagiert.
Er berichtete, dass er nicht traurig war.
Er trinkt so selten, ein oder zwei Mal im Jahr.
Alkohol und Drogenkonsum, die aktuelle wurde verneint.
Er hat in der Jugend ein oder zwei Mal HBR probiert.
An der Familie Anamnese gab es eine Pantreas-Karsinoma bei der Vater.
Die Mutter des Patienten leidete an Artilielle Hypertonie und Arithmie.
Sie war ein Einzelkind und verheiratete als Bankkaufmann.
Er hat zwei Kinder, sie sind gesund.
Die Anamnestischen Angaben deuten am Ehesten auf eine Nephrolitiasis hin.
Alternative kommen die folgenden Imbetracht, Kohlecystitis oder Kohlelitiasis.
Er hat Schmerzen in der Flanken gehabt.
Er hat ausstrahlen in die rechte Leiste.
Er hat eine Nephrolitiasis hin.
Was machen Sie an Therapie?
Wir müssen die folgende diagnostische Massnahme durchgeführt werden.
Zuerst körperliche Untersuchungen.
Beim körperlichen Untersuchungen sollen wir zuerst Vitalparameter kontrollieren.
Bei der Inspektion und Auskultation gibt es keine auffällige Befunde.
Bei Palpation und Perkussion sind sehr wichtig in diesem Fall.
Klopfschmerzen.
Ich überprüfe Klopfschmerzen.
Ich werde Blutabnehmen und Labeluntersuchungen durchführen.
Blutbild und Entzündungparameter CRP-BSG.
Elektrolytwerte sind sehr wichtig.
Urinstatus ist sehr wichtig.
Der Patient hat keine Pirexie.
Ich denke nicht Urinkultur.
Urin-Mikroskop ist genug.
Als Bildgebinde-Verfahren werde ich eine Röntgenbauchröntgen durchführen.
Dann brauchen wir Ultraschalluntersuchungen.
Viele gegebenenfalls brauchen wir City-Untersuchungen.
Was können Sie mit der Ultraschalluntersuchung sehen?
Wir können vor die Stein eine Verengung.
Entschuldige, Erweiterung.
Wir können sehen, ob wir eine Erweiterung sehen.
Man kann es sehen.
Oder ein Aufstau.
Das kann gut sein.
Die Nieren auf der Kopfschmerze kann aber auch sein,
dass sie gar keinen Aufstau mehr sehen.
Wenn der Stein schon weiter runtergewandert ist.
Manchmal, wenn sie gut sunografieren können,
können sie den Stein sehen.
Man kann eine Röntgen machen, um den Stein zu sehen.
Es ist eine eschelreiche Struktur.
Und ein Lodos CT.
Um die Diagnose zu bestätigen.
Wichtig ist Urin-Untersuchungen.
Wenn eine Mikrohemmertur da ist.
Man kann auf einem Handleiter Stein an der Neste und auch in der Klinik.
Jetzt haben Sie die Diagnose bestätigt.
Was machen Sie mit der Therapie?
Zuerst entscheiden wir,
wie groß die Stein und welche Bereiche es ist.
Zuerst müssen wir wissen,
wie lange die Therapie genannt wird.
Vielleicht brauchen wir stationäre Aufnahmen.
Vielleicht so schnell wie möglich,
eine kleine operative, dann invasiv.
Nicht invasiv.
Oder gibt es nicht,
wenn es nicht Stau gibt,
können wir SCWL,
Stosswahlen und Autorpsie empfehlen.
Wir empfehlen den Patienten viel Flüssigkeit zuvor.
Wir haben auch Schmerzmieter.
Wir müssen entspannen.
Wir haben auch Medikamente.
Wir haben vollkommen recht.
Der Stein ist wahrscheinlich in dem Oreta.
Von daher ist er schon gewandert.
Nach unten in Richtung Ostium der Hamlase.
Wenn Sie im Röntgen sehen,
dass der Stein gewandert ist,
würden Sie trotzdem eine Stosswellen-Therapie machen?
Nein.
Was würden Sie machen?
Durch Rettrug, nicht invasiv.
Durch Röhre
können wir die Stein entnommen.
Eine Zystoskopie.
Muss man den Stein wegnehmen?
Wir machen eine fossierte Infusionstherapie.
Wir warten erst mal ab.
Die entscheiden die Stein.
Wenn es sehr stark kann,
dann machen wir sofort eine Zystoskopie.
Aber kein Stau.
Wir warten auf viel Flüssigkeit.
Wir warten auf mehr Bewegung.
Wir warten auf einen spontanen Abgang.
Das ist der Stein.
Das ist ein Konkremenz.
Muss man den Patienten stationär aufnehmen?
Oder kann man den Patienten ambulant belassen?
Ich denke, aber wenn der Patient
sehr starker Staub ist,
sollen wir stationär aufnehmen.
Aber andere Weiß sollen wir nicht.
Die ambulanten Therapie.
Das ist ganz genau.
Sehr gut.
Darf ich fragen?
Ja, kann man mit den Zystoskopien
die Handleiter erreichen?
Zystoskopie?
Ja.
Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Ich bin keine Rologe.
Ich habe nicht Zystoskopie, aber die Erteroskopie.
Ja, die Erteroskopie.
Mit Erteroskopie kann ich.
Ich bin Anäste.
Ich habe viele Mal gesehen.
Die Erteroskopie können wir schaffen.
Es gibt eine zweite Frage.
Beispiel, Handleiter gibt einen Stein.
Unmöglich.
Es ist nicht verhandelt.
Können wir eine Double J-Katheter machen?
Ich glaube schon.
Ich bin keine Rologe.
Ich muss die Rologe fragen.
Ich weiß, dass zum Beispiel nach einer Stoßwellen-Therapie,
wenn der Stein in der Mierenbecken ist,
dass man dort eine Double J-Schiene anlegt,
damit das in Ruhe abfällt.
Ich bin keine Rologe.
Wenn es Stau gibt,
können wir nicht eine SWL-Therapie versuchen?
Ich glaube schon, dass es geht.
Ich weiß nur nicht, ob man das in einem Haarenleiter-Stein macht.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Aber wenn der Stau in der Mierenbecken ist,
der Stein ist groß,
dann ist es nicht so groß.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das in einem Haarenleiter-Stein macht.
Der Stein ist groß, der geht nicht durch den Haarenleiter.
Der ist 1 cm groß oder so.
Der ist kleiner.
Die Haarenröhre sollte nicht mehr als 0,5 mm erweitert sein.
Wenn der nicht durchgeht,
dann sollte man eine SWL-Therapie
oder eine operative Therapie machen.
Oder ne Krosstomi.
Ja, ganz genau.
Herr Schade hat gesagt,
ich habe vielleicht falsch verstanden,
wenn es Stau gibt,
kann man nicht SWL machen.
Ich bin nicht sicher, ich möchte...
Man kann das machen.
Ich weiß das sehr genau.
Man kann eine SWL-Therapie bei Stau probieren.
Wenn das nicht klappt,
dann sollte man eine operative Therapie versuchen.
Solche Patiente,
wie so eine Hematurie,
ich denke, so oft eine Hematurie sehen wir.
Das muss nicht unbedingt sein.
Oft ist es Mikrohematurie.
Keine Hematurie, also keine Makrohematurie.
Eine Mikrohematurie, die der Patient gar nicht merkt.
Oft ist der Patient gar keine Beschwerden beim Wasser lassen.
Er ist am Ende, wenn der Stein wandert,
und der ist schon in der Haarblase,
und von dort raus möchte,
dann tut das am Ende des Wasserlassens oft weh.
Sie haben gesagt, ich trinke zu viel Kaffee, aber ein Liter Wasser.
Ich trinke 3 Tassen Kaffee,
ein Liter Wasser habe ich gesagt.
Ich habe nicht gesagt, dass ich viel trinke.
Ist das genug für diese normalerweise man sollte
mehr trinken.
Dieser Patient, Herr Ralf Schmidt, trinkt zu wenig.
Das bedeutet 3,
dass Kaffee nicht zu viel trinken.
Kaffee ist keine Flüssigkeit.
Genau wie Cola, genau wie Papa.
Aber dieser Patient glaubt,
dass er viel trinkt, aber nicht viel.
Danke, danke.